all right, let's get into the polling news.
A lot of people asking me to talk about that,
about
this and there is a lot of interesting stuff
happening but also a lot of misreporting about
some of what's going on.
So there is big news out of the 2020 Democratic
primary, which is that there are now two polls
which show the Democratic primary to be a
statistical three-way tie between the presumed
front runner at former VP Joe Biden, Vermont
Senator Bernie Sanders and Massachusetts Senator
Elizabeth Warren.
Now the headlines are going crazy with all
sorts of claims that are not backed by the
data and they're ignoring that.
There have actually been three recent polls,
one of which paints a very different picture,
which we shouldn't ignore either.
So let's look at what we have here.
US starting with a new Monmouth poll in the
Monmouth poll.
You will see that over the last two months,
Bernie Sanders has jumped from 14 to 20% Elizabeth
Warren has jumped from 15 to 20% and Joe Biden
has dropped bigly from 32 to 19% this is Biden
down 13 points, Bernie and Warren gaining.
And when you consider the margin of error,
this is statistically at least possibly a
three way tie in the 2028 Democratic primary.
Everything else, every other candidate, basically
identical to two months ago.
So this is just one poll and it's a statistical
tie.
Uh, this is not the only pole, however, that
says that we now have a statistical tie.
There is a new economist you gov poll, which
has Biden at 22 Sanders at 19 and Warren at
17.
When you account for the margin of error plus
or minus a little more than two and a half
percentage points, you have also potentially
a statistical tie.
And then, and this is what a lot of people
aren't talking about, the newest poll of all,
uh, is a political poll, which is actually
Biden's still very solidly in the lead.
Uh, the new political poll, which is not being
talked about, very says Biden 33 Sanders 20
Warren 15, suggesting that everything is basically
the way it's been a for a month or a little
bit longer.
So generally speaking, is the race swinging
more and more away from Joe Biden?
Yes, it is.
Is it believable that Joe Biden lost 13 points
over the last two months?
As one poll says, I don't know.
I, I genuinely don't know.
It seems like a lot.
It seems that there's definitely been a shift
away from Biden and as a progressive, I want
a progressive to win the Democratic nomination.
So I'm not saying I'm not glad about it, but
I'm skeptical that Biden really lost 13 points
over the last two months.
There are still plenty of polls that have
a Joe Biden ahead, but the big story here,
there's no doubt there is a big story here
in terms of the trend line trend number one,
it's not going well for Joe Biden.
He was pulling more than 40% when he announced
several months ago.
Trend number two, Joe Biden's losses are mostly
helping Bernie and Warren, not, uh, more establishment
candidates like Kamala Harris and Pete booty
judge.
And I'm going to talk about that in a little
bit.
Uh, now at some point this is going to become
a real issue.
Are Bernie and Warren splitting the progressive
vote?
I was asked this in an audience question a
month ago, or maybe it was more like six weeks
ago.
People had been asking me, shouldn't Bernie
or Warren get out in order to let the other
progressive consolidate the progressive vote?
Because clearly if Bernie drops, Warren gets
all of his support and if Warren drops, Bernie
gets all of her support.
I am not so sure about those numbers.
I was looking yesterday.
Yes, if Elizabeth Warren drops out, uh, some
of her support goes to Bernie.
If Bernie drops out, some of his support goes
to Warren.
Uh, but there are a number of polls which
suggests that the numbers here are a little
bit different.
One survey has Sanders supporters saying their
top second choice is Biden and Warren supporters
saying their top second choice is Harris.
And what this suggests to me is that this
is much more delineated among demographic
lines than ideological.
So I don't think we should be too quick to
assume that if Bernie drops his 19% goes to
Warren or if Warren drops her 17% or whatever
goes to Bernie.
Because the polls right now are not suggesting
that that's the case.
But at a certain point there is going to be
a question of will this all work itself out?
It's a good thing to see that the progressive
movement has 35 to 40% support right now just
among Bernie and Warren, but could it at some
point prevent a more progressive candidate
from defeating Joe Biden?
That is a question we're going to be looking
at more this week and into next week.
Lastly, there are now 10 people qualified
for the third debate in a couple of weeks.
It's Biden booted, Judge Harris, Sanders,
Warren, booker O'Rourke, clover char, Castro
and Yang.
They've qualified on donor criteria and polling
criteria.
We have Tom Stier, Telsey, Gabbert, and Marianne
Williamson qualified on number of donors,
but not qualified on polling.
They may or may not be in the next debate.
Everybody else will be out.
So the number is starting to diminish and
I think that that is actually a good thing.